[Musique]
brad
est en vacances
youpi aussi avec force la
toupie site un livre pour enfants mais
il ne quitte plus roja pape avait gardé
gepam aux camions c'est devenu un outil
pour apprendre le français pour cette
professeur d'université de 49 ans qui a
fui la guerre en ukraine avec sa fille
de 27 ans anastasia nous les avions
rencontrés il ya quatre mois à leur
arrivée au québec à l'erythrée de
châteauguay
elle me parlait ni français ni anglais
si les blessures sont encore quotidienne
avec la guerre qui s'enlise la volonté
de s'enraciner ici est profonde et passe
beaucoup par l'apprentissage du français
dont les bananes avec s à la fin en plus
des cours de francisation durant la
semaine au la pratique chaque soir après
le souper avec anne-marie celle qui les
a pris sous son aile avec son conjoint
énorme à leurs familles d'accueil
québécois ce qui
l'expérience et les pieds on ne regrette
rien même si parfois j'ai des moments
qui sont difficiles
cette année
tous les jours toutes les as de
s'assurer qu'elles qu'elles apprennent
le français
j'ai eu de la misère expliqué le
français pourtant anne marie fait tout
ce qu'elle peut pour et rigide que je le
suis souvent dit a donné une poche sinon
on ne peut pas prendre de poids parce
que ça pose à la prendre au 4ème en
appartement à bienne était gris avec des
années avec un emploi parce qu'avec le
temps qui passe bien aussi le désir
d'autonomie et bien des familles
ukrainienne commence à ressentir et la
réalité ne le permet pas toujours rappel
cette intervenante notre grand
questionnement c'est la possibilité de
louer un appartement parce que les
propriétaires ne veulent pas signer des
contrats parce que la personne ne
travaille pas et pour trouver un emploi
au québec il faut normalement par les
français imaginez vous si on fait
rapidement un calcul maman et un cours
de francisation parce qu'elle ne parle
ni français ni anglais hélas deux
enfants et elle reçoit une allocation de
800 dollars par mois est ce que on peut
louer un appartement nourrir à ses
enfants sans compter le manque de places
en garderie bref un cercle vicieux
difficile à briser à moyen terme du
moins je ne vois pas comme un pur été
une conversation soutenu pour un emploi
avant au moins un an
avec la loi 96 de la cac les migrants
installés au québec depuis plus six mois
recevront des communications de l'état
exclusivement en français
l'interprétation de plusieurs ukrainien
ce qui s'ils n'arrivent pas à apprendre
le français dans ces délais ils seront
contraints de quitter le québec
évidemment que je n'hérite pas
s'inquiéter sur 10 mais voyant d'anciens
possible que quelqu'un juste que vous
deviez de récupérer au québec surtout
par les pôles france est ainsi moi
c'était foncé de mes rêves que je sais
que les gens dans leur groupe c'est leur
grand galet quiétude entre-temps aulas
et anastasia poursuivre leurs efforts
bien entouré une journée à la fois
issigeac oudry charbonneau raid au
canada lévy